فانا بس عايز اطمن
يعني الموضوع يعني السلع موجوده وما فيش
فيها مشكله ولا اي حاجه
والازمه اللي مرت علينا خلال الثلاثه اربع
شهور اللي فاتوا ان شاء الله مش ان شاء
الله
ونكمل فيها بشكل نكمل يعني طريقنا بشكل
افضل من مما كنا عليه تاني ارجو ان احنا
موضوع
يعني الكلام على على توفر ممكن يعني عشان
برضو يبقى غطيت الكلام كله يقول لك ايه بس
الدكتور علي مش قادر يسيطر على الاسواق
طيب يعني يعني وده كلام مهم يا دكتور مش
في البرلمان كلموك في النقطه دي يعني طب
طيب ما هم وده كلام مهم صحيح لان في الاخر
المواطن هو اللي بس عايز اقول لكم
النهارده يعني ده بيتكلم بيتكلم عنده هو
تبعه هو عشرين ثلاثين الف منفذ مش كده غير
منافذ بتاعه
القوات المسلحه او وزاره الداخليه يعني لو
حطيت دول معاهم كمان يمكن يخش لهم في 35
40 الف
ده عشان يحاول يخفف من
من حجم الازمه الكبيره اللي احنا بنتكلم
فيها على مستوى العالم
لكن ما حدش يتصور ايه يقول لك احنا بنخش
محل نلاقي هنا بتلاته من المحل ده بتلاته
ونص صحيح ده صحيح بس ده امر يعني يعني لو
انتم النهارده تصورتوا ان احنا ممكن كدوله
انا صادق معكم وزاره التموين او وزاره
الداخليه تقدر تقوم بدور في انها تعمل
تسيطر على ده
ده صعب
لكن احنا كمواطنين لو لقيت المحل ده غالي
ما اشتريش منه
ونبقى اديناهم الدرس انك انت مدام بتغالي
في اسعارك اكتر من من غيرك بلاش منها خالص
لغايه لما الامور تنتظم معنا ومع الجهد
اللي بنقوم به في الرقابه من التمويل
وزاره الداخليه واحنا كل يوم
وبنعلم ده وانا يمكن برضو
يعني مش مستريح كل يوم وزاره الداخليه
تطلع
مسكنا ومسكنا ومسكنا يعني يعني انت مطلعنا
شكلنا وحش قوي
بس بجد كل يوم في في النشر يقول لك
ما تمسكهم وخلاص
يعني
اتفضل يا دكتور علي